[Music]
in a village 17 kilometers west of
bakmut Ukraine's military digs new
trenches a suggestion perhaps that this
could be a new line of defense
we're leaving we remained until the very
last we wanted to stay but how can we
it's time to go
as the last remaining residents leave
Ukraine soldiers move in
Ukrainian government says it's not
withdrawing from bakmut
the Russians don't count losses neither
Personnel nor military vehicles they
push to take back moot as a matter of
principle for them and for us it's a
matter of principle to defend it it's
not just a city it's a symbol a fortress
of buckmut
the Strategic value of Bahamut is far
outweighed by its symbolic value
Russian forces have been waging an
intense campaign for months to seize
control of the small City they call
artyomovsk if they take it it'll become
the Russian's first significant
territorial advance in more than six
months
The Liberation of artiomovsk continues
the city is an important hub for
defending Ukrainian troops in the domba
taking it under control will allow
further offensive actions to be
conducted deep into Ukraine's defensive
line
Russia says it's annexed nearly a fifth
of Ukrainian territory moscow's forces
have made clear gains around Bahamut but
elsewhere the Russian winter offensive
hasn't yielded territory in other major
assaults further north and south along
the front line
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera
let's bring in journalist Yulia
chapovalova she's joining us by Skype
from Moscow thank you very much indeed
for being with us as Bernard was
explaining their buckmut is in
industrial term but strategically not
said to be that important why is it so
symbolic for Russian forces to take
control there
yes that's according to secretary
defense secretary at Lloyd Austin and
that was he's actually quote that he
said that uh Bachman had more of a
symbolic rather than strategic value
well it's just symbolic it is symbolic
and as you mentioned before President
zielinski and the command of the Armed
Forces of Ukraine zalusne and seriously
Commando the ground forces who had just
visited Bahamut they decided not to
surrender bahmoud but on the contrary
taking advantage of disagreements and
the command of the Russian army to
strike back and not only to
um to actually and blog Bahama but also
to defeat the main Russian Strike Force
the Wagner group who are left without
cover replenishment and the necessary
amount of ammunition that's according to
its head Mr preggersian the head of the
Wagner group called his situation A
piroshock or the pie when Wagner has
already almost blocked the Armed Forces
of Ukraine in Bahamut and the Armed
Forces of Ukraine are preparing to block
Wagner itself with fresh brigades and
such a scenario can be prevented if
Wagner resumes interaction with General
garasima the commander of the Russian
special military operation however the
interaction on the country has been
completely interrupted according to
precursion at the initiative of eurasima
so here we can see a very strong Rift
between Mr pregosian and the bosses of
the Russian Armed Forces but the
significance of the battle the
significance right of the battle of
bahut again increased massively as the
armed forces of Ukraine will defend
themselves here to the end and the
Russians are not going to give up either
Julia one of the things that is
fascinating to those of us watching this
situation from outside is the fact that
if guinea pig ocean seems to be able to
make such public criticism of the senior
figures within the military with virtual
impunity with absolutely no comeback
whatsoever and that seems very strange
at a time of conflict when one would
expect the military and those working in
and around the military to try to be
cohesive how is it that he is able to
make these very public statements
yeah yeah interesting isn't that because
actually yes he's allowed to say a
little bit more than the rest of us here
uh because you know if an ordinary
person starts criticizing the the
special military operation here in
Russia uh they can be you know put in
jail for quite a you know a number of
years
um so there is as they've been said many
times that there is a rift between you
getting pregosian and the Russian Armed
Forces but just not only with them
because we see a lot of you getting
progression on the internet we read his
telegram Channel and we see all those
criticisms not just towards the Army but
also to address
um to the mayor of Saint Petersburg for
instance and people who are standing
behind him so and it means that we are
witnessing some sort of internal power
struggle when all those groups and
alliances and factions
um starting to you know fight with each
other and you know for some sort of for
for a fair share of power for for a fair
share of you know of Mother Russia and
its wealth and uh at the helm of all
that we'll have Mr Putin who's very
effectively uh holding back all those
wonderful people and uh basically
controlling uh this rivalry and by that
I mean by those wonderful people I mean
of course the representatives of the
siloviki or the the security services
like the FSB police National Guard and
other people uh oh sorry can you hear me
yes Julia we can thank you
oh sorry because there's something wrong
with with the connection that's all
right yeah Julie I tell you what we're
just going to leave it there because we
are having a few problems with the
connection but uh Julio sharp of Oliver
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us from Moscow thank you
thank you